moi je le dis haut et fort nos
agriculteurs sont les premiers à
entretenir à protéger et à préserver
notre environnement c'est les premiers
acteurs stéphane je voudrais avoir ta
vision en tant que céréaliers de ces
normes qui t'en met quasiment tous les
jours et voir d'après toi les solutions
efficaces rapides concrètes pour
vraiment les arrêter ou vraiment les
faire diminuer rapides et concrètes
c'était pour mon temps d'intervention
maintenant j'ai deux ou trois minutes
quand même on cherche dieu tu as 3
milliards car j'en viens trois minutes
trente minutes 50 becqueter je suis ravi
d'être avec vous aujourd'hui je suis
producteur de céréales dans le loiret
mais aussi membre de cette de cette
famille politique dans le loiret et
j'anime aussi ici la fédération des
métiers de la terre ce nombre de mes
collègues sont là et je les remercie
d'être là tu producteurs de céréales
juste pour parler un petit peu de la
crise comme nous parler mais mes
collègues éleveurs tout à l'heure en
2015 le prix du blé a été seulement 18
jours au dessus du prix de revient dans
une exploitation agricole
c'est pour vous dire à quel niveau on se
situe le toutes les productions vous
l'avez dit vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure sont touchés alors qu'on
pourrait penser que si le prix des
céréales est très bas ça devrait aller
ou en tout cas donner un petit coup de
main à l'élevage non le prix des
carburants de l'énergie est très faible
ça vaut pour les céréaliers ça vaut pour
les producteurs de production animale ça
ne sont 500 change rien puisque la crise
est toujours là donc on est bien dans
une crise structurelle de l'agriculture
de notre pays et qui doit être prise en
compte d'une manière très très forte
mais je suis ravie d'entendre depuis ce
matin qu'on doit dans notre famille
politique à droite considéré qu' une
exploitation agricole est une entreprise
que la surface de l'écran soit 3
hectares où 3000 hectares c'est une
entreprise agricole et qui doit se gérer
comme une toute entreprise et que chaque
millimètre de compétitivité qui est
perdu par rapport à nos concurrents
eh bien elle est quasiment irrattrapable
ou en tout cas c'est très très difficile
et c'est là où est le problème
parce que dans les grandes productions
agricoles françaises nous sommes sur un
marché international
la compétition elle est internationale
faut que ce soit le blé que ce soit le
port que ce soit le lait la complet la
production elle et pas uniquement
française
on ne peut pas dire à cet instant la
france va décider que le lève autant que
le blé votant non parce qu on est sur un
marché international
et c'est là où notre problématique c'est
que l' écoute de production globaux de
l'ensemble de nos productions et bien
chaque année où chaque heure augmente et
augmentent plus que nos concurrents
parce que on a un certain nombre de
charges que nos concurrents n'ont pas et
que nous nous mettons dit boulet au pied
chaque jour bon donc hélas sur
transposition et les normes
d'une manière générale ils sont pour
quelque chose les normes mais angélique
que je parle devant j league sur les
normes européennes
les normes européennes ce sont les
normes européennes on n'est pas obligé
de l'est sur transposer en france
je vais prendre deux exemples ou en tout
cas de lait complexifier la politique
agricole commune et les déclarations pac
que chaque agriculteur fait c'est une
directive européenne
bon eh bien je vous indique par exemple
que dans l'ensemble que les dossiers
agriculteurs remplissent il y à un
secteur qui est les surfaces non
agricoles est saine
ah bon parce que effectivement on n'a
pas à toucher des aides ou de
subventions sur les surfaces on ne
produit pas non agricoles eh bien la
france a créé une telle usine à gaz en
2015 ce que disait mon collègue tout à
l'heure que les dossiers pour 2016 ne
sont pas prêts et qu'on est en train de
découvrir entre 100 et 200 anomalies par
exploitation agricole sur les surfaces
non agricoles voyez donc sur un petit
point de du dossier d'une taille et bien
on est en train de créer quelque chose
qui va bloquer l'ensemble de l'activité
d'envoyer la sueur transposition
pourquoi parce que la ddt travaille de
son côté
l'hygiène qui fait l'écart travaille de
son côté et tout ça tout serein
travaillent pas ensemble
donc moi je compte beaucoup sur la
droite et notre famille politique pour
mettre tout ça en
là sur les nitrates la directive
nitrates est une norme est une directive
européenne
bon et bien en france chacun travaille
de son côté
vous avez la chance de bassin loire
bretagne fin de son côté seine normandie
qui travaille de son côté la dtcc trail
de son côté je vois là et on arrive au
bout et bien avec des tas de dossiers à
remplir
personne n'a les mêmes conditions les
mêmes normes dans une région par rapport
à une autre
et ça c'est de la sueur transposition et
ça complexifie les choses deux dernières
petites choses parce que on parle
actuellement on installe sur le les
salariés des complémentaires maladie
chirurgie c'était très bien dans les
entreprises c'est tout à fait normal
notamment pour les gens qui ont des cdi
dans les exploitations agricoles la
lecture étant un employeur de main
d'oeuvre mais mais vous voyez par
exemple quand un agriculteur veut et
marada la grippe
il peut faire appel à un service de
remplacement pour traire ses vaches le
soir eh bien le système n'est pas adapté
et on se rend compte aujourd'hui il en
place depuis le 1er janvier que le gars
qui est venue faire la traite c'est son
collègue guy culteurs il doit plus
d'argent il doit lui rendre plus
d'argent à cause de cette histoire de
complémentaire mais on est tombé sur la
tête on tombe sur la tête
donc nous devons moi je crois je compte
beaucoup sur notre famille politique sur
la droite dans le projet pour dire c'est
une c'est un grand secteur économique
nous allons le prendre en compte comme
jamais et entre l'europe en belgique la
france et parlementaires et les régions
et nos collègues des régions qui
viennent de l'emporter et qui ont un
rôle extrêmement important à jouer tous
ensemble nous allons mettre en place une
organisation qui fera qu' aucune entrave
aucune norme supplémentaires aucune sur
transposition viendra gêner la
compétitivité parce que c'est le mot-clé
voilà donc il faut enfin redonner c'est
pas un coup de baguette magique
il faut juste se poser toutes ces
problématiques là les régler ensemble
sur les différentes strates voilà